[Music]
welcome to the review of the iphone 11
pro
[Music]
right off the bat i don't really agree
with the names i don't think there's
enough pro about these phones that could
have been to warrant putting pro in the
name
but the names don't really matter what
does matter is these are the highest end
phones that apple makes right now in
2019. the truth is these are mostly
pretty familiar phones to last year
which was also pretty familiar to the
year before but you already knew that
what's new is apple's really focused on
four
major things for this new iphone so the
design
barely
the new display slight upgrade the
battery life
major
and these new cameras so the design does
grow on you not gonna lie we saw those
renders and the models and nobody
thought they were pretty including me
but as usual getting them in your hand
and actually looking at them in person
is a different thing and it doesn't look
horrible i love the new matte finish i
think that helps a lot the way it looks
the way it feels even if it is
technically a little bit slipperier than
glossy i will take a matte option in any
phone every time the camera square is
the weird looking part
i'm just happy we got memes out of it uh
and it's funny for whatever reason the
camera square looks indented even though
it's sticking out it's all cut from one
piece of glass and it's kind of like
this weird optical illusion i guess but
this is the design that apple's crafted
for the iphone 11 pro camera bumps in a
camera square and yes it rocks slightly
when it's on a table apple does say that
this is quote the toughest glass in any
smartphone
i'm not going to test that but let's be
real glass is glass so you definitely
want to protect it or at least try not
to drop it it probably still will
shatter but the good news is it doesn't
seem to scratch as much as the pixel 3's
matte black glass that this reminded me
of so the matte finish and the camera
layout are the only really new things
back here with the design if it comes
down to it if you don't want to have to
think about it anymore or just want to
avoid any chance of fingerprints or
scratches you can grab a grip from our
channel sponsor dbrand and this matte
black robot skin on it is actually a
limited edition thing so link below if
you want to check that out but around
the front of the phone it's going to
look like almost exactly the same thing
as last year same screen sizes and
resolutions same notch same bezels
literally you could put it next to last
year's phone and you might have a hard
time telling which one's which
this is the new one here so this is
what's actually different apple said
they've improved face id to be up to 30
faster in the same space and work at a
larger variety of angles i can vouch for
a tiny bit faster and you'll only really
notice this if they're side by side with
the old phone but you know what i'll
take that improvement anyway because
it's for security and that's better than
nothing but the variety of angles thing
i don't know about you but when i read
that i was hoping that meant it could
sit on a table in front of you and still
read and unlock your face like it
couldn't before
but it still doesn't do that
unfortunately you still got to do that
lean
onto whatever surface the phone is on to
unlock it
so i've noticed honestly no improvement
here in the angles
it's basically the same other than that
the buttons are very very slightly lower
on each phone i don't know if anyone
else has shown that but that's true
i guess maybe it's a little easier to
reach and they've also upgraded the
water resistance a bit still ip68
certified and this phone is very
slightly thicker and heavier i didn't
really notice the thickness but i did
notice the weight especially in the pro
max this big phone is 20 grams heavier
than last year and i could tell it's a
bit of a chunker but you know what
that's perfectly fine because
battery life is back to being excellent
on this phone as a result this is also
achieved by getting rid of 3d touch so
rip apple watch is really the only new
apple product now with 3d touch shipping
in it but by getting rid of that
pressure sensitive display hardware
that's allowed more space in the phone
for a bigger battery it's true the
teardowns have shown it the battery is
bigger so that's why the battery
difference from the 10r to the 11 was
one hour that's just a13 bionic
improvements but the improvement from
the 10s to the 11 pro was four hours
because getting rid of that 3d touch
hardware has left room for more bigger
batteries i don't know if i can measure
that four to five hour claim but from my
experience battery life has been
excellent i'm getting you know my use of
super high brightness high end
everything on all the time i'm getting
seven to eight hours of screen on time
and a full day of battery
pretty much every day on this phone so
that's really impressive you can
probably kill it in a day
but you'd have to really try now back to
that display for a second i mentioned
they got rid of 3d touch this has been
mostly replaced by haptic touch which is
essentially long presses that bring back
almost all the functionality from 3d
pressing
it's not quite as good as the peak and
pop was
but i hardly use that anyway and there's
also something new about the display
specifically that it can hold a higher
800 nits of brightness and at small
points for brief moments can peak up to
1200 nits which is incredible on a
smartphone display and also it's up to a
2 million to 1 contrast ratio so of
course they had to name it
they named it the super retina display
xdr
the name is pretty lame but the display
is impressive again indoors and outdoors
now could you tell the difference side
by side with a 10s watching a youtube
video or playing a game or even
scrolling instagram
probably not but there are certain times
certain times when watching a movie or
something in hdr where you can notice
that improved brightness and it looks
great and the sound is also pretty good
thanks to the improved speakers even
though there's still a notch you know
the highest iphone display has always
been pretty great and this is no
exception it's better again but i can't
help but think what would customers have
noticed more a slightly improved
brightness
or shrinking the notch a bunch
you know that's something we'll get more
into later for now what you need to know
is the iphone 11 pro and pro max have
even better awesome high resolution oled
displays again and they're also a bit
more efficient contributing to even more
battery gains so that's worth it oh and
the specs
they almost don't matter on an iphone
review but since people are always
curious it is the new a13 bionic chip
this year which is excellent and four
gigs of ram in these pro phones
according to geekbench it's still
extremely fast as any new phone should
be
most of these improvements over the a12
are just going to help these stay faster
for longer and as it's been said they'll
be appreciated more near the end of the
phone's life than the beginning all
right i almost can't believe i made you
guys wait this long
for the cameras
so clearly the cameras are if you've
watched any of the ads or any of the
presentation videos these cameras are
the main focus for the iphone 11 pro yes
that's a pun so you've seen it we're
looking at triple cameras now three new
sensors so you have the primary 12
megapixel sensor a 2x telephoto camera
and a 0.5 x ultrawide camera about 120
degree field of view and it's true the
iphone 11's cameras are a big
improvement over the 10s in broad
daylight i would go as far as saying
this has been an a plus camera often
taking the best sharpest and cleanest
photos i've seen a smartphone take
colors are great they're realistic so
not too over processed dynamic range is
excellent and of course with subjects
their tonal mapping is next level it's
really good which helps it of course in
tougher shooting scenarios where it's
improved a lot over the 10s so the
typical iphone 11 pro photo is i think
the closest to what the human eye sees
of any smartphone camera and i'm
including the pixel on that which tends
to be a little contrastier a little more
dramatic but then of course
the ultra wide camera
finally i've been waiting for this i've
been waiting to see what an iphone ultra
wide camera would look like lg done it
samsung did it
motorola did it asus did it oneplus did
it huawei did it everyone had already
done it ultrawide we just wanted to see
basically what google and apple would do
with their new cameras so we finally
have an iphone ultra wide and it's uh
it's fine it's pretty good it's actually
really fun the main advantage should be
consistency with the other lenses and
color wise white balance wise it is it's
very consistent but in quality and
detail thanks to the smaller sensor and
slower glass it is still noticeably a
step down it's softer there's a little
more noise reduction doing more
smoothing on the ultrawide camera so
it's just generally not as good quality
as the main camera which is to be
expected but that doesn't stop it from
being awesome to have for these new fun
perspectives and all the awesomeness
that comes with an ultrawide camera the
new ui also in iphone's camera app is
improved for the first time in a while
you know they've simplified a few
controls brought them to the bottom
where you can reach with one hand and
now when you open it you get a preview
of what's going to show up in the ultra
wide if you switch to it
but i
i don't really want that there i i think
it's kind of cool that it shows what you
could see
but when i just want to take a normal
photo it's kind of distracting it lags
behind a little the actual framing and
it's not perfectly aligned all the time
so i want to turn it off
but i can't it will fade out
automatically when it detects that
you're taking a photo of a close-up
subject since i guess it recognizes that
ultra wise or more for landscapes or far
away subjects and then it'll come back
automatically when you put that close
subject away but yeah i want to be able
to just shut it completely off there's
also now finally a dedicated night mode
which turns on automatically when it
thinks it's dark enough but sometimes
it's kind of dim and it doesn't turn on
when you want it to but there's no way
to manually turn on night mode which
isn't very pro but okay when you do get
it turned on the ui is excellent it
gives you exposure equivalence so you
can turn up or down live and it will go
for way longer times if it detects
you're on a tripod or stabilized and you
can see the picture sort of brighten up
as it's being taken almost like it's
exposing the frame in real time which is
pretty sick and the shots you can get
now at night and in low light on the
iphone are very good there's no clear
overall winner i think for best night
mode right now in my opinion they also
do it a different way here's my take
night mode is good enough that i wish i
could turn it on more often i think the
natural curious comparison here is with
pixel's night sight the pixel definitely
tends to brighten up photos more and uh
bring shadows up bring highlights up you
can it's it's more of like a night time
to daytime transformation sort of
situation happening there with pixel
where the iphone is a bit more true to
life and then it's also taking what i
think are the most detailed sharpest
low-light photos of any smartphone even
more so than the pixel but in dim light
it just it doesn't turn on very much and
there is no night mode in the ultrawide
camera so really it's a great start but
no doubt it can get better over time i
think this will make a really good blind
smartphone camera test if we if we do
like a separate bracket specifically for
phones that have a dedicated night mode
now which is a lot of them i think that
could be really good but just in general
i am really happy that there's this new
focus on smartphone cameras i feel like
the last year of presentations of
smartphones have had more time spent on
the camera than any other feature and
they're all just fighting against each
other to try to make the best possible
camera to put in our pockets
and we win from that the iphone 11 pro
still does the best video of any
smartphone that's still pretty clear to
me and they're also making it easier now
in the ui to just quickly start taking a
video so if you see something you like
you open the camera up and just hold
down the shutter button and it just
starts recording so just like instagram
or snapchat and if you want to lock it
into video recording you just drag it
over to the right and it's hands-free
you're taking a video but yeah in the
photo front the competition is pretty
stiff and it's coming from all different
directions we're about to get pixel 4 we
just had the new huawei mate 30 pro come
out oneplus 7t is right around the
corner you can count on that stuff and
then i just want to touch on ios 13 for
a second so i've been using it in beta
on my iphone 10s max before this came
out so i've already used the things you
get again here like dark mode and the
long presses and quick settings and
stuff like that it's great a bunch of
little tweaks here and there but i gotta
say it has been kind of buggy i've had
some weird issues with lock screen
controls just not showing up sometimes
sometimes the camera app just freezes
all together until i close it and then
i've had some other weird app issues
with like the tesla app and instagram
app but now those are fixed so yeah i
should definitely mention that hopefully
ios 13.1 and future software updates
will iron a lot of this stuff out
otherwise it's ios as you'd expect it
also for those wondering the u1 chip in
these new phones which should again
basically give you ultra wide band
signal for
referential locating of other u1 enabled
devices and should improve airdrop
that's not enabled in this version of
the software i think that's also coming
in 13.1
um aside from that we don't really know
what else it does but generally the
software experience of the iphone is
pretty much unchanged
same ui same feature set you already
know what it is nothing is dramatically
or drastically different here beyond i
think night mode so i'm not super
surprised here look you you probably
don't need
an iphone 11 pro
but it is a great upgrade like
especially when a lot of these
improvements even though they're small
are on such core functional things to
normal people like speed
battery life
and camera like if you were to ask
normal people what they care about the
most in their phone it's those things
but i've said it before and i'll say it
again a lot of the features that i was
looking forward to especially when we
heard it was going to be a pro phone
are just not here and that's got me
hyped way too early for this
2020 iphone or the iphone 12 or whatever
they call that and actually new design
shrinking the notch maybe usb type c of
course a high refresh rate pro motion
display that would have been super pro
uh putting touch id back underneath the
display glass
reverse wireless charging any of these
things in this phone would have been
would have would have felt a little more
pro and would have maybe made it worth
the name or just felt really cool to
have but of course none of it happened
so really the focus for this new iphone
11 pro has come down to the a13 the
battery life the slightly improved
display
and just these new cameras you want it
you got it if you're just someone who
wants the best possible camera in your
phone or if you do a lot of video
creation or if you're a pro content
creator on your phone
then you're going to be really happy
with this phone with the new iphone
classic or even with the new iphone 11
non-pro which is 300 cheaper and has the
same cameras and same processing and a
great battery life minus the telephoto
but again that much cheaper price
that'll get its own review but i'll say
as a whole the iphone 11 pro
is a really great phone and unless you
have the 10s it's probably worth the
upgrade just for the love of cameras
but really the big looming reason for
someone like me not to get this phone
is the 2020 iphone or the next iphone so
that's something to think about but
we'll stay ready for that as i expect a
lot more
but this package they've shipped today
it's pretty damn good
either way that's been it thank you for
watching
catch you guys the next one
peace
you